[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASHISH AGARWAL: Hi, I'm Ashish.
I'll be talking
about ML Toolkit.
So let me start by saying
that TensorFlow is this really
amazing piece of technology.
At Google, it's already
powering systems
ranging from search ranking,
ads auction, YouTube
recommendations, Translate,
Photos, and many, many more.
We can train complicated
models with hundreds
of billions of
parameters and solve them
on platforms ranging from mobile
phones to cluster of TPUs.
However, TensorFlow is this
really low-level framework.
As Martin mentioned
in an earlier talk,
we are working on high-level
parameters like layers,
estimators, losses,
and metrics to make
it easier for researchers
and developers
to create custom
model architectures.
However, what's still
missing from TensorFlow
is algorithms that
work out of the box.
What a lot of
developers really want
is packaged solutions that
they can quickly and easily
integrate into their workflows.
So I'm happy to
tell you that now we
have a toolkit of really popular
machine-learning algorithms
that we have built right
on top of TensorFlow.
So starting with linear and
logistic regression, k-means
and Gaussian mixture models
for unsupervised clustering
of data, WALS matrix
factorization,
which is a popular collaborative
[INAUDIBLE] algorithm
for the computer systems,
support vector machines, all
the way to state of
the art algorithms
like SDCA, Stochastic
Dual Coordinate Ascent,
for context optimization, random
forest and decision trees,
and various architectures
of deep networks.
Now, all these are
available on GitHub,
and we are constantly working
on improving and expanding
the site.
Next I'll highlight a
few of these algorithms
to give you a better sense
of the existing and upcoming
features for these algorithms.
Starting with k-means.
So here we implemented the
standard layouts iterative
algorithm, along with random
and k-means++ initialization.
We support both full batch
and mini batch training modes,
and we also allow the user
to specify distance functions
like cosine or Euclidean
square distances.
Now GMMs, on the other
hand, model the data
as a mixture of Gaussians.
These are much more powerful
models, and also harder to
train.
For these, we use an
iterative EM algorithm,
and we allow the user to choose
from a combination of means,
covariances, mixture
weights to train on.
Next, we have WALS, which is
matrix factorization using
Weighted Alternating
Least Squares.
I will be revisiting this
later in my talk, as well.
So here, you are given
a very sparse matrix.
For example, you
could be given ratings
that users have
provided on videos.
Note that the matrix is
sparse, so not all the videos
are being rated by each user.
And now you want
to answer questions
like, which video should you
recommend next to the user,
or to find user-user similarity
or video-video similarity.
Now, this is typically done by
factorizing this huge matrix
into a product of two
factors, two dense factors.
Note also that, as the
algorithm indicates,
this loss is weighted, which
allows you to, say, downgrade
things that were unrated in
the original input, or to avoid
spam, or popular entries from
drowning out the total loss.
So this value is
highly nonconvex.
However, it turns out, that if
you fix some of the factors,
there's a close analytical
solution for the other factor.
And so the training
works in an iterative way
where you, first,
fix V, compute U,
then fix U, compute
V, and go on.
Next, we have SVMs.
So these work by finding
a decision boundary that
maximizes the margin.
We are working with soft margin
methods using a hinge loss,
and the current implementation
is of linear SVMs
with L1 and L2 regularization.
Note that SVMs become much
more powerful with a nonlinear
kernel, which allows a much more
complicated decision boundary.
So we are working on providing
nonlinear kernels using
the kernel approximation trick.
Next, we have SDCA.
Now here, you have a
convex loss function
with L1 and L2
regularization, and SDCA
uses a neat trick of
transforming this last function
into a dual form.
And it turns out that,
for many problems,
solving it in the dual form
is much more efficient.
And it turns out
that this algorithm
can power models from linear
and logistic regression all
the way to SVMs.
We also have random
forest and decision trees.
Random forest are
[INAUDIBLE] decision trees,
and decision trees
work by creating
a hierarchical partitioning
of the feature space.
Currently our training
method is what
we call "extremely random
forest training," which
allows better
parallelization and scaling,
and we are also working
on having gradient
boosted decision trees, which
are very, very popular also.
So I talked about the
different algorithms.
Now we want to make it
really, really easy for users
to use them.
All of these are exposed via
very high level scikit-learn
inspired estimator APIs.
Here's an example for how when
[INAUDIBLE] k-means clustering.
So you start by creating a
k-means clustering object,
and here you can pass
in a bunch of options,
like the number of clusters,
how you want to train,
how you want to
initialize, and so on.
Next, you call the fit function
and pass it your input,
and that's it.
Not tons of logos
behind the scenes.
It creates the graph for you.
It'll run training iterations,
configure the runtime
until the training is done.
When you're finally
ready, you can
start inspecting the model
parameters like the clusters,
and start running inference,
here finding the assignment
to clusters, and so on.
So I talked about
high-level APIs,
but you also want to
maintain the flexibility
and extensibility that
TensorFlow promises.
So these are not opaque
objects that are only
accessible via this API.
They, in fact, allow the
users to inspect the graphs,
and also to be able to embed
these graphs into larger
training models.
So here's a training-- here's
a [? trial ?] example that
embeds k-means as a layer
in a bigger, deeper network.
You start with an
input, you run k-means,
and get your graph for k-means.
It also returns your training
op to drive the clustering,
and the output is the input
transformed to a distance
to cluster space.
Next, you feed this to
your dense stack of layers,
you create your
supervised loss, you
run STD to get a
final DNN training op.
Now you have these
two training ops,
you can join them to
create a single training
op that can drive the core
training of these two models.
Here's a code
snippet for the same.
So you start by creating
this k-means object,
and you'll inspect
the training graph.
It returns you a training
op and the output.
Next, you feed your
output into dense layers,
and you create your model
architecture as usual.
Finally, you get the training op
to drive your supervised loss,
or your dense stack.
And finally, use TensorFlow's
group operation to group
together these ops, so
that you have a single op
to drive the co-train.
So just to recap
the talk so far,
I talked to you about
the different algorithms
that are available now.
I showed you examples for how
to use high-level APIs to access
them, and also talked about
flexibility and extensibility
of these algorithms.
Next, I want to
highlight the fact
that all these
algorithms are backed
by distributed implementations.
Just to give you a better
sense of the complexity hidden
behind these few lines
of byte and code,
I will dig deeper into
the implementation
of one of the algorithms.
So, in general, the
distribution architecture
is going to do the same.
You'll have a set of
parameter servers, which
will store all the
parameters in a sharded way.
You will have a bunch
of worker replicas
that will be running
training steps,
with many batches of inputs.
In each step, the worker replica
would fetch some parameters.
It will run compute on the
input to compute the new value
of the parameters.
And finally, it will
write back these updates
to the parameter server.
So let's look at WALS again.
Just to recap,
with WALS, you want
to factorize a really sparse
matrix into dense factors.
And as I told you,
the training algorithm
involves fixing
one of the factors,
computing the other
one in your training.
Now I want to be able to scale
to inputs that are terabytes
in size, and you
want factors that
have hundreds of millions of
rows and hundreds of columns.
So how do you make this work?
So we have to carefully think
about all the RAM, compute,
and info bottlenecks.
The first obvious
thing is, given
the size of these factors, you
will have to distribute them
across parameter server shards.
So you take a U, split them
across all these shards.
Next thing, given the
amount of compute involved,
you want a bunch
of worker replicas.
The sharding scheme that we
use for these worker replicas
is row slicing.
And what that means
is, each mini batch
is a subset of
rows of the input,
and we compute the
corresponding rows of U.
Note, however, there's
still a problem.
Each update to U depends
on the full V factor.
And as I said, V could be
large, it could be terabytes.
So what this entails
is that you might
be copying terabytes of data
to each worker in each step.
So how do we get around that?
So at this point, we use
some [INAUDIBLE] magic.
It turns out, you can
compute certain summaries,
let's call them G. And
given G, your updates to U
only depend on a few rows of
V. And these are specifically
the rows that correspond to the
non-zero entries of the input.
So this is great.
What that means is that,
instead of copying terabytes,
you can just copy
megabytes of data per step.
At this point, we can run
TensorFlow's gather operation
and get the required rows.
We then compute using highly
optimized custom C++ kernels
that we wrote.
And finally, we use
TensorFlow's scatter operation
to write back these updates to
the parameter server shards.
So how well does this work?
We believe our implementations
are really high performance.
We did some benchmarking,
and on single machine,
our implementations,
in general, look
on par with scikit in terms
of model quality and speed,
often even working faster
for moderate-sized problems,
as well.
But where TensorFlow
really shines
is being able to run seamlessly
across hundreds of thousands
of machines.
In fact, in many cases,
we are able to train
models that are much
larger than what
we had seen in [INAUDIBLE].
For example, with
random forest, we
were able to train thousands of
trees with billions of nodes.
And we have a paper at
NIPS that talks about that.
With SDCA, we saw 10x to 50x
faster convergence compared
to Google's highly optimized
internal [INAUDIBLE]
implementations on logistic
regression for [INAUDIBLE]
with billions of examples.
With WALS, we are
able to factorize
a huge matrix, 400 million
rows by 600 million columns,
into factors with 500
columns in under 12 hours.
Note that this is
50x larger than what
we could do with an early
MapReduce-based implementation.
So, in summary, we have really
high performance distributed
and extensible implementations
of different ML algorithms
that are working out of
the box in TensorFlow.
These bring together
the ease of scikit
with the power and
scalability of TensorFlow
and moves TensorFlow one
step closer to being a more
complete ML solution.
I am hoping, at
this point, you guys
are excited to get
started, so here
are some links to core
and documentation,
and here are a
bunch of estimators
that are ready to use.
With that, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]